buon natale a tutti quanti in ritardo
come va con l'estate come sono passate
le vacanze babbo natale vi ha portato
quello che volevate perché io vi ho
portato non una recensione
tanti auguri è lo so avevo detto che
avrei fatto la recensione natalizia ma
sono qui a non farla ea grattarmi perché
non avevo né vogliamo soprattutto nel
tempo e non so perché c'è questo
riverbero o dicevo perché non ho avuto
ne voglia ma soprattutto tempo perché io
sono furbo nel video dove dico che non
ho più voglia di fare recensioni dico
però le farò ancora una natale ma se
porca [ __ ] se non hai voglia perché ti
fai un natale
mannaggia a me però volevo farla per
davvero avevo anche comprato alcuni
materiali per farla ma purtroppo non ho
avuto tempo e quindi piuttosto che non
fare nulla
faccio un bel video quindi chi si
aspettava una recensione mi dispiace
arrivederci per tutti gli altri vi
dovrete sorbire un video dove racconto
la mia storia che cazzo ce ne frega a
noi
ottima risposta questa è quella cosa che
non avevo mai fatto cioè il raccontarvi
la mia storia avete presenti titolo my
story quelli che su una lavagnetta
bianca o su un foglio bianco disegnano
la loro storia da da quando sono nati
fino a dove sono arrivati con youtube
questo sono io e potete notare che a un
certo punto mi è finita la penna nera e
ho dovuto cambiarla con quella viola
questo è il computer con cui ho fatto i
miei primi video dov'è questo sono io
nel mio primo video e questo e youtube e
capirete da voi perché non ho voluto
continuare a farlo ha disegnato sconti
pippen al accorgo dopo e quindi partiamo
e partiamo subito con una cosa che metà
delle persone sarà l'altra metà no io mi
chiamo karim con la k perché mai questo
nome che suona molto simile ad un tipo
di kebab semplicemente mio padre ha
origine araba e più precisamente dall
iraq mentre mia madre pugliese
e io sono nato lì in puglia in una
cittadina chiamata monopoly la mia
infanzia è stata divertente
immaginatevi un piccolo basso ragazzino
con gli occhiali tondi avevo degli
occhiali tondi che harry potter non è
però non era ancora tanto famoso c'erano
solo i libri quando io ero piccolo e
nessuno lo conosceva ringraziando iddio
almeno quello che la sono scampata i
capelli che non so se l'avete votato
adesso si vedono persone un po più
lunghi all attaccatura che un arrivo
invece all attaccatura che qua ma mi
fanno naviga e mezzo che ringrazio mia
madre per questo grazie mille e quindi
mi fanno quando sono lunghi tendono a
farmi lari che io tendo di da
nasconderla facendo ogni due secondi
così e quando ero un po più piccolo
melate mi tenevo la riga avevo la riga e
mezzo quindi immaginatevi un tappo con
gli occhiali tondi e la liga in mezzo
che si chiama karim e arriva da monopoli
al divertimento alle elementari e alle
medie come ti chiami kalim come karim
con la k come karim come mi sembra
difficile
karim come stefano mi chiamo stefano e
questo alle elementari alle medie dopo
l'attentato alle torri gemelle dell 11
settembre
le cose sono un po cambiate come ti
chiami karim con la k o vende un
terrorista
scherzavo spero che tu moglie in un
incendio che era sempre meglio di quelli
che mi dicevano sei nato monopoli che
pedina sei solo quella che adesso ti
prende a calci nei [ __ ]
e poi ovviamente c'è stato il periodo
quando ero più piccolino che volevo
cambiare nome perché tutti si chiamavano
marco alberto io invece mi chiamavo in
quel modo buffo poi in realtà è passata
e chi cacchio se ne avrei capito ormai
tutti sono incuriositi ovviamente che in
puglia ci sono persone che si chiamano
karim i geni è la mia vita interessante
finisce lì prima di arrivare a youtube
c'è non ero per niente è bravo a scuola
0 e la gente si stupisce perché di ciò
che dio ha la barba incolta il pizzetto
gli occhiali la riga e mezzo è un
secchione e di quelli proprio no invece
in proprio zero
mi piaceva scrivere quello sì mi piaceva
scrivere da morire
una cosa che mi è rimasta ancora
parecchio infatti tutto quello che a
parte i primi video ma poi ci arriveremo
gli ultimi da dal centesimo in poi sono
tutti iscritti perché sono decisamente
meglio e mi piace scrivere è come ho
detto la mia vita adolescenziale è
abbastanza noiosa prima di youtube non e
non mi ricordo che sia successo niente
di che e arrivato un computer a un certo
punto è da lì la mia vita è
completamente sfasciati sfasciata
completamente grazie a battezzarlo si
ricorda video luogo fatto del secondo
canale e basta e passato la vita a
volere un emilio e meglio è
non ho mai avuto e alla fine arriva a
youtube nel 2006 ottobre 23 25 non mi
ricordo adesso ottobre 2006 capo il mio
canale youtube perché ho scoperto
youtube e scopro video ignobili
c'erano video ve lo ricordate il periodo
i video di cattivi simpatici ecco non è
mai morto quel periodo perché quando
sono arrivato io non c'era nient'altro
che gattini simpatici in realtà c'erano
due youtuber semplicemente che tra cui
il youtuber che ho seguito di più in
assoluto che era gugliemo uil lucera
c'erano lui e make you make up ma non me
ne fregava nulla e la mente contorta ma
non sono un grande fan dei che saluto
per l'amor di dio quando sono un grande
fan dei degli scherzi telefonici poi
l'inizio del mio canale più o meno lo
sapete ormai ho caricato come primissimo
video caricato scrubs perché in quel
periodo della mia vita guardavo scrubs
dalla mattina alla sera non è vero lo
sci chiuso in tv però ne parlava dalla
mattina alla sera con gli amici ho
cambiato il mio umorismo cambiato il mio
modo di vestire anche grazie a scrubs ma
di quelle sono altre cose può poi sempre
cercando su you tube e non solo su
youtube scopro l'angri videogame nerd
che qualcuno di voi
saprà sicuramente chi è qualcun altro no
andatevelo a cercare perché merita
veramente è uno dei capisaldi di
recensori di giochi brutti cioè tutti i
recensori che recensiscono giochi brutti
adesso sicuramente hanno preso spunto
dalle i videogame nerd ho detto perché
non prendiamo la palla al balzo e
prendiamo spunto dall individuo gameland
e così ho fatto
e molti di voi lo sanno male i miei
primi video e veri e proprio per il
disagio caricavo cagate tipo qualche
prova di effetto speciale con una
telecamera orrenda che faceva video
tutti zigrinati una roba incredibile
successo delle patatine col olio friol
il mio primo vero e proprio video alla
yotobi chiamavo le sono state e tipo 56
non mi ricordo neanche più perché no
tolte 30 anni fa gameplay possiamo
trovarli o recensioni di giochi brutti
ma in realtà non era recensione giocavo
per tipo 5 minuti e poi banali
prendendoli da una lista chiamata lunghi
peggiori giochi del nintendo e da
qualche parte ce n'è ancora qualcosa
magari faccio vedere qualcosina
ok il gioco che vi presento oggi è
deadly towers deadly towles è primo
nella classifica della top twenty dei
peggiori giochi del nintendo mai fatti o
mamma mia è la prima cosa che si vede la
grafica purtroppo che c'è i colori dove
sono e tutto in monocromo come se si
giocasse sul game boy strano che le
abbia tutti sono così belli questi video
però poi ho detto non è che funzioni
dato non solo bravo a parlare e dal non
sono bravo a parlare ho detto perché non
ci facciamo vedere direttamente in
faccia in realtà è perché lì ho scoperto
il nostalgia critiche non sa gea
critique insieme a e in grigio insieme
alcuni sì ma un sa di padre jones siamo
un altro un gruppone di youtuber parrano
youtuber tutti amiconi diciamo della
nostalgia critique da cui appunto tutti
i recensori di phil bruti hanno preso
spunto da
la nostalgia critiche chi più chi meno
io non così tanto alla fine
ok i miei primi video erano praticamente
non dico la copia ma e quasi quasi il
format era molto simile al suo dio tv
direi una cosa normale all'inizio quando
sai cosa fare prendi spunto qui e là
però i miei primi almeno tre o quattro
video ero veramente tanto di ispirazione
ai suoi è quindi faccio uscire la mia
prima decisione visto che comunque io
film brutti rivederlo
comunque io i film brutti ne mangiamo
parecchi e così siamo al nemico stefano
prima ancora di fare la recensione di
mortal kombat ii distruzione totale che
è il mio primissimo fini recessivo
abbiamo fatto tre o quattro video dove
io e lui eravamo seduti su una sedia che
sono dorati relativamente poco e
parlavamo di un film visto prima e dopo
la visione da lì in poi è scattato le
nostre critiche è ho detto facciamo
mortal kombat ii è uno dei miei film più
brutti perché la gente dice che mortal
kombat è meglio e che morto al comma 2
un po così no secondo me sono due film
veramente di merda però va bene così ho
fatto la recensione di mortal kombat ii
distruzione totale
salve quello che vi presento oggi è il
seguito di un film uscito nel 1995 di
nome morta come se ogni tanto riguardo
quel video di che adesso è super super
privato su youtube che vi chiedo ma come
cazzo faccio ad avere tutti quegli
iscritti c'è se fossi stato in uno di
voi non mi sarei mai scritto grazie il
video ma in realtà grazie quel video lo
sei iscritto nessuno perché non avendo
una base di iscritti o avendone vi
sembra un centinaio grazie i video di
giochi non facevo visualizzazioni perché
nessuno sapeva che esistesse
e allora facevo 100 200 visualizzazioni
che per me erano tantissime perché se tu
fai metti non ha in sé le scritte e
metti un video con il video fa 200
visualizzazioni che non solo tu e che
continui ad andare a vedere
probabilmente 50 visualizzazioni romy
che continua a andare a vedere se
c'erano committee però parte quello
qualcosa c'era lily ancora non c'erano
iscritti ma io neanche li cercavo perché
non avevo idea di come cercare gli
iscritti non potevo spalmare più intanto
non conoscevo quasi nessuno
e quindi mi buttavo e quel che succedeva
succedeva
poi un giorno ho fatto ho fatto altre
due recensioni di giochi è successo una
roba sul mio dito
una era quella di etile extraterrestre
considerato il gioco più brutto della
storia dei videogiochi
l'altra era di b clic su uno dei giochi
meno finiti della storia dei videogiochi
dei greens invece l'ho fatta con i
cinque punti mi sembra che fosse uno dei
primi video fattori cinque punti non mi
ricordo neanche mi sembra di no però
quella recensione è stata poi messa in
un forum chiamato cazzate punto con mini
con un forum di cazzate comunque che si
chiamava cazzate qualcosa
immaginate il livello però grazie a quel
forlì molta gente mi insultava perché
comunque il video una merda secondo voi
quanti tipi di videogiochi ci sono tre
fondamentalmente quei livelli quelli
brutti e quelli inutili poi ma soltanto
poi c'è b cristeros pò d animo per fare
sti video vi era una marmo ortore che
però per intrattenere un po parli un po
meglio ti metti uno schifo di maglia un
po più colorata e dio santo
grazie a quei video linee è arrivata la
più grande quantità di gente agli inizi
e si parla che sono passato da 0 a 3
mila diciamo così buona parte degli
iscritti anche arrivata grazie al video
di dolo azzurri che adesso l'ho tolto
perché non lo zoom purtroppo esploso a
causa della finanza ecco il video li lo
sponsorizzava un po ed era stato messo
in nel fu nella pagina del forum di
modulo a zone in home page e questo
abbiamo portato un sacco di di dice che
quindi ringrazio ancora i proprietari
della zona che problema adesso mi stanno
guardando dal dal televisore con le
grate della prigione per tutti i video
fino al centesimo sono andati lisci poi
dal centesimo in poi ho detto no ci deve
essere un cambio assoluto e ho cambiato
stile
se prima c'erano i cinque punti non 5
numero 4 che secondo me sono le
le recensioni prigioni che io abbia mai
fatto compresa quelle che poi mi hanno
fatto veramente esplodere come quella di
amore 14 è di vendita cdo stanno mi
sopporto più erano un po così le
recensioni ma i video youtube non erano
tanto diversi all'epoca era la era la
golden age di youtube e dicevo voi da
centesimo video in avanti è cambiato
tutto è cambiato lo stile ho iniziato a
scrivere le cose o tonto vie cinque
punti che era una roba vecchia o sono
andato a riprendere un po lo stile degli
americani diciamo così quello senza
punti tutto liscio dall'inizio alla fine
del film però ho sempre cercato di
evolvere il mio umorismo e farlo mio e
cercare di non copiare troppo gli altri
perché è ovvio che quando guardi una
cosa e tu dici voglio fare quella cosa
lì è ovvio che ci prendi un po e ci
vuole tempo per ci vuole pratica per
avere tuo
qualcosa pero che con mostarda quello
che arriverà a gennaio sia proprio il
punto cardine del me stesso del me
stesso che scrive cose che fanno ridere
la gente si spera e niente poi da lì in
poi sono successe allora la mia vita è
sempre stata abbastanza noiosa youtube
la ribaltata completamente aveva ragione
il principe di bel air questa è la maxi
storia di come la mia vita è cambiata
capovolta sottosopra è già finita c'è
già finita già finita poi dai quei 3.500
iscritti è partito tutto quanto piccoli
raduni tra youtuber raduni con i fan
alle fiere soprattutto alla torino
comics a milano alla fiera di milano a
cartoomics lì la gente diceva a
salutarmi ea farmi i complimenti per i
video e io io che sono una persona
timidissima ma veramente tanto tanto
tanto dice
ai temi dei file video così non c'è
invece da menez non c'e nessuno ha mai
veramente vi giuro non c'è nessuno
dietro la telecamera
finché è così posso dire quello che
voglio il problema inizia quando devo
parlare con un'altra persona e non solo
fa quando a scuola la maestra la
professoressa ti dice poi andare alla
terza c e chiedere di dice può andare
petrulli io sto per avere un attacco
cardio respiratorio
sono sempre stato così youtube mi
piacerebbe dire mi ha aiutato soprassare
non cazzo o comunque problemi a parlare
con la gente qui parlo normalmente se
devo parlare con un'altra persona di 21
rincoglionito dalle terre proiettato
succedeva una cosa bruttissima dove io a
questa mania di ringraziare sempre
grazie grazie perché gli altri di solito
quando fanno i complimenti a meno che
non arriva qualcuno che vi dirà una
gomitata su dell'occhio vi dicono
complimenti per i video grazie
continua così grazie mille e il suo
secondo sì ma ogni tanto non succede ma
io supporto a raffica di complimenti per
i video grazie mille continua così
grazie grazie davvero cosa fare
quest'estate grazie mille grazie ciao
grazie e quindi mostarda
mostarda sarà sfondo bianco me che parlo
tanti saluti e arrivederci abbastanza
cattivo
niente siglava bello poi lo vedrete
questo è il tra l'altro l'ultimo video
che farò nell'ufficio che se vado a
vivere da solo a breve fa i due mesi e
sono a vivere da solo questo il mio
obiettivo
due mesi vado a vivere da solo e questo
ci saluta e quindi ciao ciao ufficio mi
mancherà soprattutto la polvere di
quest'ufficio il canale di gaming sta
andando molto bene ma quello non lo
prendo in considerazione perché è una
paraculata una parlata che vada bene nel
senso cioè e grazie me li porto da casa
iscritti poi che a loro piace min sono
contentissimo a me piace farlo ma quello
è un è una parentesi a parte gli hot
hobby come ho detto il canale secondario
chiuderà gli addobbi diventerà mostarda
scordatevi loew toby delle recensioni
allegrotto sarà tutto abbastanza acido
come la mostarda e basta perché se no
ripeto sempre le stesse cose
quindi io vi auguro di passare delle
vacanze incredibili perché ve li
meritate
io vi ringrazio per tutto quello che mi
avete fatto passare ma io sto morendo e
non è che muoio come video scorso che si
ma ho fatto un video ma che cazzo di
video fa ma perché non mi avete fermato
sembrava stessi mondo sembravo un
requiem sembrava di un salto mancava
solo
l'api dalla fine con scritto gli ottavi
1988 2013 quindi noi ci salutiamo ma ci
rivediamo a gennaio perché dal 7 gennaio
non il 7 gennaio dal 7 gennaio inizierà
mostarda nella casa nuovo probabilmente
forse più mostrando lo farò ancora qui
poi lascerò e quanto sapevo mi
raccomando a capodanno non fatevi
obiettivi che poi non raggiungere mai
l'anno scorso mi hanno detto che avrei
fatto mille di accuse invece la mia vita
l'anno scorso c'è il 2013 per me è stato
completamente travolgente mi ha travolto
inaspettatamente con mille cose diverse
molte cose negative moltissime cose
positive molte cose molto negative ma
questo è un altro discorso
quindi non fatevi uniti non potete
raggiungere sai cosa ed io però se
evitati sbattere la porta che sto
parlando quindi non fate gli obiettivi
questo è l'obiettivo che vi dove sono
questo è un obiettivo che vi do da fare
per capodanno non date di obiettivi che
non potete raggiungere mai nel 2014 lo
dovete vivere per come arriva come farò
io sì non verrò più uno numero più
studiano di più
troverò lavoro
gli esami mi laureo in roma prendetelo
per come arriva altrimenti non ne
usciamo vivi grandi bacini se fra dieci
anni magari di torno in quest'ufficio ed
è ancora così come vi ringrazio per
tutto quanto vi ringrazio per questo
immenso 2013 ci vediamo in un 2014 che
non ho idea di come sarà
non c'è
no